bonjour et bienvenue dans fit l'écho
dans ce nouveau numéro on s'intéresse à
l'industrie et plus précisément à la
baisse que cette activité dans le
département
nous reviendrons aussi sur la
mobilisation nationale de la cgt
et puis nous découvrirons cette
pépinière d'entreprises basées à magny
les hameaux et spécialisée dans
l'innovation industrielle aujourd'hui
industrie représente plus de 90 postes
dans le département soit 4000
établissements et ces chiffres sont en
baisse
henri watrin bonjour vous êtes élu à la
chambre de commerce et d'industrie de
versailles et vous êtes également
directeur de thales en basé à elancourt
spécialisé dans les systèmes
électroniques pour commencer une
première question comment se caractérise
cette baisse de l'activité dans le
département cette activité a perdu de
l'ordre de 15 % d'emplois ça fait un
petit peu moins d'un pour cent par an
c'est beaucoup moins que le reste de
l'ile-de-france qui a perdu la moitié de
ses emplois mais c'est quand même une
érosion lente et qui n'est pas saine et
qu'il va falloir juguler
pour pour trouver les moyens d'un
redressement et comment est-ce qu'on
peut expliquer cette baisse quels sont
les facteurs principaux
les facteurs principaux pour les
appréhender il faut se souvenir un peu
de ce que c'est qu'une entreprise
une entreprise c'est une réunion de
femmes d'hommes et de moyens qui
conçoivent et fabriquent des produits
qui sont destinés à être vendu à un
client c'est la définition de
l'industrie parce que voilà c'est vrai
que par industrie on pense dans les
yvelines notamment à l'automobile
mais finalement c'est beaucoup plus
large que ça c'est beaucoup plus large
que ça est ce qui fait que la santé de
l'entreprise c'est finalement son niveau
de vente
lorsque l'entreprise vend ses produits
elle crée de la richesse c'est avec
cette richesse l'investît et elle crée
des emplois et lorsque l'entreprise
n'arrive pas à vendre ses produits
eh bien elle perd de l'argent et donc
elle réduit ses investissements et est
amené à réduire ses effectifs
donc la clé du problème c'est bien la
lente et le petit problème
supplémentaire dans la vente c'est qu'il
ya de la concurrence
généralement internationale et il faut
donc pour que l'entreprise vendent
qu'elle amène sur le marché des produits
meilleurs que ceux de son contenant et
donc vous le disiez c'est finalement les
carnets de commandes qui sont de plus en
plus vides les plans sociaux
s'enchaînent on pense notamment un psa à
poissy
quelles seraient les leviers à actionner
pour faire redémarrer cette activité
pour faire démarrer cette activité il
faut faire re décoller les ventes
donc amené des produits de bonne qualité
sur le marché à des coûts compétitifs
donc la compétitivité d'une entreprise
c'est ça c'est un bon produit et un coût
modéré en tout cas moindres que ceux de
ses concurrents
donc les leviers ils sont claires et
connues il ya l'innovation pour être
capable de d'imaginer
et de concevoir les produits du futur le
deuxième levier important c'est la
formation pour que l'entreprise dispose
de personnel qualifié et puis enfin il
faut modérer les coûts salariaux et en
particulier les taxes qui pèsent sur ses
coûts et puis dernier point
l'aménagement du territoire les
transports par exemple dans la région
parisienne pour que l'entreprise puisse
se développer sans être asphyxiés par
des temps de trajet trop important voilà
déjà 4 levier important sur lequel on
peut agir est donc l'un de ces leviers
vous parliez de l'innovation
industrielle effectivement le premier
ministre marc ayrault organisera début
novembre un séminaire à matignon pour
relancer le chantier la compétitivité
industrielle donc vous disais ça fait
partie des priorités pour pouvoir faire
repartir cette activité c'est donc une
préoccupation du gouvernement est ici à
la chambre de commerce et d'industrie de
versailles quelles sont les initiatives
je crois que cette initiative déjà du
gouvernement et est louable parce qu'il
faut remonter un peu l'image déjà de
l'industrie qui a une image un petit peu
négative d'un nom dans la population ce
qui ne lui permet pas d'attirer par
exemple des jeunes dans ses services
alors la chambre elle prend des
initiatives bien sûr et en particulier
au niveau national on a décidé de faire
de 2013 l'année de l'industrie mettre en
avant l'industrie avec tout un tas de
d'activité prévu le discussions de
prises de position de deux forums pour
soutenir l'industrie qui sont là qui en
a bien besoin
merci beaucoup henry watrin d'avoir
répondu à toutes ses questions et on
parlait donc du dialogue local pour la
mort c'est le conseil général organiser
une table ronde pour faire se rencontrer
syndicats et représentants patronaux la
chambre de commerce étaient aussi
présentes
c'était à la veille de la mobilisation
nationale organisée par la cgt on
regarde ce reportage
ces syndicalistes du technocentre
renault à guyancourt s'apprêtait en
début d'après-midi à rejoindre paris
pour manifester à l'appel de la cgt à
l'occasion de la journée européenne de
l'industrie étaient également présents
des salariés de l'usiné renault flins et
de peugeot poissy
la veille lundi le conseil général des
yvelines avait organisé une table ronde
entre syndicats et organisations
patronales pour échanger sur l'avenir de
l'industrie dans le département et faire
des propositions
nous sommes porteurs d'une proposition
de la tenue d'assises industrielle au
niveau départemental qui puisse
regrouper tous les acteurs de la filière
la désindustrialisation n'est pas fatale
elle est le résultat de la crise du
système qui vise à une rentabilité
financière toujours plus importante et
on pensons qu'il ya des choses à faire
pas donc le crédit bancaire peut servir
au développement industriel à la
recherche
l'intérêt c'est effectivement de
voir comment le conseil général peut
s'impliquer un peu là temps et voir
effectivement comment on peut structurer
les actions coordonnées étaient
peut-être faire du lobbying c'est un peu
le message aussi qu'il nous a été passée
par rapport à la question effectivement
du transport par rapport à la question
du logement son plan légal il existe un
outil qui était la gestion
prévisionnelle des emplois au niveau des
territoires
et ça il faut l'utiliser il faut
l'utiliser aussi au niveau département
ce donc j'avais besoin moi n'était pas
d'avoir des dossiers mais c'était cette
remontée du vécu par les par les
entreprises par les les les syndicats de
ce que vivait le au quotidien leurs
adhérents seul bémol à cette réunion
informelle l'absence des organisations
patronales medef et cgpme
l'industrie représente 16 % de l'emploi
dans les yvelines avec 80 mille postes
soit 2% de moins qu'en 2008
premier acteur toucher les constructeurs
automobiles et leurs sous-traitants
nous voici à présent dans le cluster
gennari à magny les hameaux
spécialisée dans l'innovation
industrielle pour l'automobile et
l'aéronautique je suis avec gérard
d'albon jour vous en êtes le fondateur
et le président et vous fait donc partie
de l'un des six pôles de compétitivité
que compte le département
comment se porte votre groupe étant
donné la conjoncture qui n'est pas très
bonne notamment dans l'industrie
écoutez nous sommes pas touchés pour
l'instant donc scellier certainement la
dynamique des différentes pme qui
composent le cluster donc il y a
dynamique de groupe quotidienne qui
s'affichent des visites des clients
intéressés un marché qui est toujours
donc intéressé par les différentes
compétences qui sont au sein du cluster
et pour nous donc il n'ya pas de
contraintes particulières donc lié à la
crise au contraire
ici il y à 6pm dont certaines qui
travaillant pour des groupes automobiles
notamment renault ou encore psa
certains groupes automobiles mettent en
place des plans de départ un des plans
de licenciements et pourtant vos pme
ont toujours un carnet de commandes
fourni oui c'est les compétences
spécifiques qui sont plutôt rares mais
qui permettent donc d'accompagner des
développements qui sont toujours en
cours malgré les plans sociaux pour
relancer l'activité industrielle l'un
des axes à développer c'est de relancer
la compétitivité l'innovation
on se rend bien compte qu'ici les six
pme qui travaillent l'une à côté de
l'autre travaille aussi en synergie et
c'est donc là l une des clés
oui tout à fait à écouter l'important
c'est de mutualiser des des coûts est
ici les entreprises des pme peuvent donc
avoir accès à différents services sans
avoir à recruter un daaf recruter donc
un ingénieur système donc les coûts sont
partagés et bien évidemment une
compétitivité économique
et puis donc partir du principe que ce
sont des pme des gens qui ont les
responsables de pme ont un savoir-faire
très élaboré il se consacre au
développement de l'entreprise et
l'ensemble des coûts qui sont
nécessaires donc fonctionnement de
l'entreprise quotidienne d'une peine au
quotidien sont mutualisés quel est
l'avenir pour généralise qui compte six
pme
il nous reste 150 m² de bureaux ils
n'auraient 600 m² d'ateliers et dans ce
cadre là donc je souhaite éventuellement
de séduire de nouvelles pme en
cooptation avec les autres pme actuelle
pour éviter des conflits d'intérêts et
une fois que donc les locaux seront sont
tous occupés on verra comment faire pour
éventuellement reproduire ce projet là
soit en france avec les pme existantes
de telle façon qu'elles puissent
continuer leur croissance soit
l'étranger si le classe se présente donc
d'année prochaine
les prochains mois et prochaines années
merci beaucoup gérard d'elle nous allons
maintenant partir à la rencontre d'une
de cpm qui fait partie du cluster et qui
est spécialisée dans le câblage et
l'intégration électronique
nous sommes dans l'atelier de câblage de
la paix m
m6 toujours dans le cluster generis à
magny les hameaux michael vivien bonjour
je vous travaillez dans cette pme
comment se porte votre activité
principalement tournée vers l'industrie
automobile alors assez paradoxalement
par rapport à ce qu'on pourrait penser
vu le contexte ça se passe plutôt bien
le coeur de notre activité donc vous
vous y êtes c'est de la fabrication de
câblage pour les prototypes automobiles
et on est dans une niche qui se porte
aujourd'hui plutôt bien on travaille
essentiellement avec les services de
recherche et développement pour lesquels
on va élaborer des prototypes de
faisceaux électriques pour les véhicules
qui sortiront dans l'avenue votre pme a
été créé en 2009 le cluster dans lequel
vous êtes installé aujourd'hui a été
créé en 2011
est ce que vous avez vu un regain ou une
augmentation de notre activité
depuis vous faites partie de ce cluster
oui sur 2011 environ à 30 %
d'augmentation de chiffre d'affaires de
quelle manière est ce que vous voyez
l'évolution de votre pme dans ce cluster
c'est d'accueillir d'autres pme pour
toujours créer des synergies et une
compétitivité alors nous à notre échelle
ça va passer déjà par une
une phase d'augmentation en termes de
ressources puisque la demande la demande
de nos clients est croissante
on va essayer de se positionner sur des
activités d'intégration électronique
également ce qu'on fait en bureau
d'étude et essayer de s'ouvrir sur
d'autres domaines d'activité peut-être
de des systèmes d'aidé à la personne on
travaille beaucoup sur des nouvelles
technologies donc tout ce qui est pavé
tactile et on peut pourquoi pas imaginer
travailler pour les personnes à mobilité
réduite travailler sur les véhicules sur
également les fauteuils qui sont qui
sont développés pour ces gens on va
essayer de se positionner beaucoup plus
loin et de proposer des services d'après
vente aujourd'hui on s'est affilié avec
une société qui s'occupe de la
maintenance des ambulances des systèmes
de signalisation d'autoroute et donc
nous on leur propose des prestations et
des interventions sur tout ce qui est
électrique
merci beaucoup michaël julien mercier
avant de se quitter on jette un coup
d'oeil à l'agenda
la cité des métiers attrape organise le
8 novembre un nouvel atelier autour des
métiers du maraîchage bio la chambre de
commerce propose le 9 novembre une
réunion d'information sur la reprise
d'entreprise s'est ouvert au public et
c'est gratuit
c'est terminé pour ce numéro je vous
retrouve le 9 novembre pour un nouveau
fil échos